[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio des filières où on est en direct
on est avec vous c'est figaro live et on
attend vos points de vue emmanuel macron
s'est-il ridiculiser avec la vidéo de
mcfly et carlito on a des bas comme
chaque mardi avec alexis brézet bonsoir
exil on rappelle que vous êtes directeur
des rédactions du groupe figaro est avec
nous ce soir avec vous dominique reynié
directeur de la fondation pour
l'innovation politique la fondapol
bonsoir dominique qui pousse sur le fond
et on signale la sortie de ce livre très
intéressant le xxième siècles du
christianisme ouvrage que vous avez
dirigé et qui vient de paraître aux
éditions du cerf
alors on y reviendra pas ce soir mais on
y reviendra une prochaine fois soit on
reviendra sur l'autre polémique du week
end celle qui a opposé audrey pulvar à
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur a renoncé à finalement à
porter plainte contre la tête de liste
ps en ile-de-france at-il eu raison et
bien on attend vos points de vue il y a
donc eu plus de 10 millions de vues vue
pour la vidéo qui a buzz et tout le
week-end celle des youtuber mcfly et
carlito venu défier comme promis
emmanuel macron à l'elysée et ça dure
une trentaine de minutes et ça commence
comme ça
cette phrase est folle j'essaye de nom
mais j'essaye de un peu congestionné
pour avoir l'air bien dans mon t-shirt
qui arrive regard rien ne va dans ce
regard désolé on arrive sur le président
vous faites pas ça vaut des mouchoirs
sur ce mécène il ya un service de l'udc
les amis
alors je tiens à vous préciser que c'est
pas les coulisses de l'émission où le
bonus qu'on met à une fois que le
générique est passé non c'est vraiment
comme ça que commence la séquence avant
d'aller plus loin dans le décryptage
alors parce qu'il ya après 30 minutes
avec le comme le veut le genre une
concours de d'anecdotes
est-ce que emmanuel macron s'est
ridiculisée ou plus exactement à
ridiculiser la fonction alexis vous
allez dire que c'est par l'accusé lui
même je crains malheureusement qui nous
est ridiculisé nous qui les ridiculise
et nos institutions présidentielle c'est
quand même vertigineux dire que le
président de la vème république le chef
d'un état qui n'est peut-être plus la
puissance qui a été par le passé me
facture est quelque chose qui compte la
surface du globe
l'héritier des rois qui ont fait la
france se met en scène avec des guignols
pour savoir s'ils se mettent des trucs
de papier sous les aisselles et font des
culs des cabrioles et des roulades dans
les cour de delhi est dans le nom mais
c'est que c'est invraisemblable et s'est
essayé à proprement affligeant
à l'odyssée le moyen de parler aux
jeunes je crois qu'on peut leur parler
d'autre chose d'autre chose aux jeunes
et qu'on peut leur parler autrement je
pense que c'est une manif est un profond
mépris de la jeunesse que de croire
qu'on ne peut lui parler que de
footballeur de métaux rock métal et de
deux blagues à trois balles sur savoir
si quand on a fumé un pétard en sus à
s'arrêter par les flics aaa
je pense qu'il ya des jeunes dans ce
pays que la majorité des jeunes d'un
peuvent s'intéresser aux choses qu'on
peut les intéresser
il ya des jeunes qui font des choses qui
en a qui ont envie de faire des choses
qu'on n'a qu'une envie de s'engager et
que simplement il faut savoir des tirer
vers le haut et que d'une manière
générale un homme d'état c'est de là
qu'ils tirent une nation vers le haut et
pas qui c'est de la rabaisser dominique
une politologue coco naissantes comme
chloé morin dit plutôt que le président
s'en est bien tiré et que finalement
cette ceux qui dénoncent une
réutilisation de la fonction
présidentielle oublie de dire que ça
avait déjà commencé
elle donne des exemples sous giscard ou
bien un peu plus tard avec yves mourousi
interrogeant fesses sur la table
françois mitterrand non mais c'est pas
c'est pas une mauvaise idée de rappeler
des précédents qui ont en leur temps pu
étonner pas autant que je crois que
celui là mais qui ont pu étonner en leur
temps parce que ce sont des comme des
moments de ou voilà de réajustement par
rapport à des attentes que l'on croit
deviner dans l'opinion
et puis claude morin appartient
la nouvelle génération des politologues
d'analystes donc peut-être aussi un
effet de génération ça c'est bien bien
probable ce que ce qu'on peut imaginer
bien sûr c'était ça vient d'être dit on
peut imaginer que on ne sait pas comment
s'adresser à cette partie de la société
française qui est assez largement
abstentionnistes des intéressés par la
politique telle qu'elle se fait on peut
pas imaginer qu'on va continuer à lier
après année à se passer de ces
générations dans les yeux dans la vie
politique il ya un effet avec l'âge ça
ce ça s'atténue mais c'est vrai moi je
trouve aussi que c'est une réduction de
la jeunesse a une image qui ne la
représentent pas tout cas pas
entièrement
et puis les deux mois je connais pas ça
je me suis entendu est peut-être si je
vous disais que je connais bien mais je
ne les connais pas et les deux
animateurs que j'ai vues sont pas mis
une première jeunesse n'ont plus à
manger pas le sentiment en tout cas j'ai
donc bon il ne faut pas l'impression
d'avoir 16 ans 18 ans carrière derrière
eux oui non mais c'est à dire non mais
c'est ça c'est ça bah c'est la première
chose qui m'a étonné c'est à dire que ce
sont des entrepreneurs qui font au fond
qui font les affaires avec une idée de
la jeunesse mais c'est pas la jeunesse
donc s'il ya des il ya des il ya des
étapes je dirais intermédiaire par
ailleurs si on veut ré intéresser la
jeunesse la pratique est oui et bien sûr
que c'est nécessaire donc en foutez lui
parler de politique
2 mais est ce qu'il ya eu un seul
message politique dans cette mission qui
durent 30 puis du 30 mai ce qui est
admis un quart de message politique
c'est quand même une différence
considérable quand mitterrand ce mets
tes s'affaisse sur la table de livres
musique à l'époque ça nous paraissait
mais c'était seymour aussi bon peu
importe
c'était une émission de deux heures on
ne parlait que de politique d'ailleurs
ça s'adresse pas du tout jeune homme
affable mais mais c'était l'idée d'avoir
mais en parler de politique mais là il
n'y a pas une seconde le seul message de
cette de cette demi heure c'est je suis
cool c'est ça que ça veut dire c'est pas
de la politique je suis groupe e
emmanuel macron qui pense à des
prochaines élections présidentielles qui
voit que dans son image à des éléments
jugé négativement qui se dit que c'est
important décide de faire venir à lui la
jeunesse veut faire
c'est un message je suis sympa je suis
cool mais c'est parce qu'on nous dise
pas que c'est pour intéresser la
politique à la jeunesse s'il avait voulu
faire passer un message politique par la
vie partisane mais je la cia et en plus
il ya des youtube heures qui parle de
politique
il y en a plein il y en a il y en a des
ddd youtuber moi non plus je suis pas un
expert mais depuis je me suis un peu
renseigné mais qui qui peuvent s'appeler
hugo décrypte qui peuvent s'appeler jean
macé qui est analyse qui font du
décryptage assez neutre il ya des dd
youtuber d'ultra gauche y en a beaucoup
il y en a d'autres à droite y en a
quelques-uns mais ça prouve que on peut
à travers ces et qui sont des vases
jeunes cela et qu'on peut a traversé
s'adresser si on veut faire passer un
message politique très intéressés la
politique mais c'est pas du tout le
sujet sait flatter les passions dire oui
comme il est cool il peut téléphoner
qu'il ya des maps et en faisant semblant
d'improviser mais à qui on fera croire
que évidemment tout est prévu tout est
cousu de fil blanc
il se promène dans le dangereux à
l'elysée il dit [ __ ] ils l'ont fait
parce que il découvre qu'il découvre
qu'il ya un orchestre de hard rock au
fond du palais du parc de visite mais
ils ne découvrent pas il ya eu 27
autorisations qui ont été demandés avant
d'installer des musiciens au fond du
parc et lisez donc tout est faux tout
est fait que ça sert juste à montrer
combien découle qu'on était sympa
combien les modernes mais qu'on nous
dise pas que c'est pour intéresser les
gens la politique c'est pas vrai donc
vous dansez pas que ça peut toucher une
jeunesse en particulier une jeunesse
moins diplômés qui votent moins raconte
le pen et qui affectionne ce genre de
vidéos moi je pense que ça peut toucher
cette partie de la société
je pense même que ça peut avoir un effet
positif
du point de vue de l'image du président
par contre la grande difficulté on la
connaît bien c'est de transformer une
opinion un avis sur sur une personnalité
et de passer de ça à un comportement
électoral doit les faire voter dans un
an
ceux qui auront eu alors si on ne fait
rien il se passe rien mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya peut-être d'autres modalités
pour expliquer aux générations que de
toute façon elles devront faire de la
politique
le creux de toute façon elles auront des
responsabilités et que les affaires
publiques vont les concernés elles
devront avoir un point de vue là dessus
c'est absolument nécessaire
et puis il ya aussi voilà l'institution
scolaire enfin il ya il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de clés pour évidemment que
c'est à toucher des jeunes puisque n'a
touché par millions des audiences elles
elles sont pas fausses ça touche est
exactement comme une marque c'est une
démarche qui est commercial les grandes
marques je vais font ça quand elles
veulent déplacer leur image de paiement
chez les jeunes elles se font appel de
youtube heures qui vont activer leur
communauté et à 13 ans on va adresser un
message à cette communauté et par là on
espère déplacer son image plein de
grandes marques notamment de luxe font
ça avec les appelle les millénium en
disant il faut qu'on compare la ces
jeunes et c'est bon donc c'est du
marketing
donc ça fait ça fait du président de la
république un produit qu'on va exposer à
une nouvelle cible et on calibre le
message pour cette cible
au passage les marques qui vont sassou
train de se dire oui c'est très bien
ex-aequo didier sait on touche donc on a
des like on a des du rich c'est ça le
vocabulaire un de ceux de ce genre de
méthode de quotas on va toucher des
millions de gens méritent un au delà de
ça ce voit tel résultat est ce qu'on
transforme ça en actes des scandales
est ce que c'est un acte d'achat ben les
marques c'est à dire ben non parce qu'on
détruit ce qui fait notre notre essence
c'est ce qu'ont produit la qualité de ce
qu'on produit l'image qu'on renvoie le
rêve qu'on renvoie pas pour la politique
c'est un peu la même chose
oui bien sûr il va toucher des millions
de monde il est marrant les un vrai dire
elle est marrant les enjeux des gens
vous diraient c'est un vieux boomer qui
fait croire qu'il est jeune ça va se
partager bon mais ça va toucher des
millions de gens mais ce que ça fera
voter pour lui est-ce que sar et
intéressera les jeunes à la politique
est-ce que ça n'intéressera notre destin
collectif à la france
moi je ne suis pas du tout sûr c'est ça
la vraie bataille c'est de faire que la
jeunesse s'intéresse à la france sur
figure aussi un article qui a cartonné
il est signé du politologue mathieu
slama qui jeûne et enfin plus jeunes
comment et qui dit qu'un cap un cap est
franchi dans la dépolitisation de la
parole politique je vous propose
d'écouter il réagir à une autre analyse
celle d'alexis devriez il est historien
de la presse il vient de publier ce
livre jupiter et mercure le pouvoir
présidentiel face à la presse est donc
sacré essentiellement sur l'étude à la
façon dont emmanuel macron s'est adressé
et à utiliser ou bien des rappeurs de
manuel macron avec la presse il voici
comment il analyse la séquence et lui il
exprime une forme d'inquiétude
on l'écouté l'inquiétude qu'on peut
avoir c'est cette façon qu'il a toujours
et depuis là encore ce lait début de son
quinquennat et même la campagne cette
façon d'exclure ou de d'évincer les
journalistes dès qu'il le peut ce rêve
d'une désintermédiation d'une parole
présidentielle qui pourrait échapper au
regard journalistique et moi ce qui
m'inquiète dans cette séquence là c'est
que presse était précisément ce qu'il
fait ça nasa veut et une défaite pour
les médias d'avoir ces deux ce genre de
séquences mais un ami peu importe bien
sûr est quelque chose de douloureux pour
l'ego des gens disent qu'on passe plus
par umeå limite c'est pas ça qui est
important
si le présent afrique veut s'imposer
directement français si même il veut
passer par d'autres truchement que les
médias pour le français mais qu'il le
fait qu'ils leur dis des choses grande
des choses qui élèvent l'esprit des
choses qui relancent ce pays qui donnent
d'eux mais moi ça me va très bien on
n'est pas là pour défendre une
corporation c'est pas le sujet le
problème c'est quand le président est
tellement heureux d'être au centre du
spectacle qui commence à faire à dire je
vais te donner la patrouille de france
pour le 14 juillet puis je mettrai la
photo de ces deux de ces guignols sur
sur mon bureau quand je m'adresse au
fait c'est pas un jeu d'être président
d'un public
on n'est pas là pour rigoler pour les
gens ça représente quelque chose et là
ils disposent de des attributs de la
présence comme s'ils te son bien
personnel une espèce de 2,2 le principe
le plaisir qui moi me paraît très chaud
quand je dis pas que ça marchera pas un
peu peut-être qu'il ya des jeunes
toujours bien mais ça me paraît sur le
plan des principes et sur le plan de la
vie extrêmement choquant l'afer qui lui
le fait qu'il ait parlé ou non déjà 10
me paraît au regard de sa c'est
secondaire
il ya certainement un risque aussi qui
tient à la la période
alors c'est vrai que j'imagine que ses
pensées aussi avec la le set se
déconfinement que le que l'on connaît
l'idée aussi de créer une participer en
tout cas à la création d'une forme
d'enthousiasmé collectif pour
accompagner le déconfinement et la
reprise mais mais mais c'est encore une
période difficile pour beaucoup il ya un
risque de contre-pied et puis on l'a vu
l'actualité internationale a n'a pas
manqué évidemment de d'exprimer des des
dimensions dramatiques donc on est on
est un peu on a un peu en déphasage
répondu ah c'est ça qui me paraît risqué
mais je songe et aussi à une controverse
qui avait eu lieu pendant la campagne
2007 qui m'avait beaucoup frappé à
l'époque où on avait reproché je sais
pas si ce mot on avait beaucoup pointé
le fait que ségolène royal et nicolas
sarkozy à l'époque était avait beaucoup
investi la presse people mais pas non
plus pour dire des choses c'était plutôt
pour montrer leur vie etc et je sais pas
si c'est la seule raison
mais en tout cas sélection la plus
participative la présidentielle 2007
peut-être aussi parce que dans des
milieux qui n'était pas généralement
destinés à être mobilisés on avait reçu
une sorte de message qui avait amené à
rentrer dans le jeu finalement le taux
de participation en 2007 est remarquable
on n'a pas retrouvé depuis
on vous pose la question entre le cas
sur twitter emmanuel macron s'est-il
ready
lisez lors de la vidéo de mcfly et
carlito et ceux qui ont répondu vous
avez été nombreux à répondre vous
répondez oui à 64% je vous donne la
parole puisque vous commentez à la fois
sur twitter youtube et sur le site du
figaro anna il reste sérieux même dans
une vidéo fun sans faire le guignol donc
rien de choquant pour moi angélisme il y
ait au contraire ils élèvent la fonction
plus accessible c'est gaëtan sur youtube
le plus ridicule et cette stratégie de
communication il est en train d'assurer
sa réélection en allant chercher les
jeunes
on a vu justement que c'était pas même
si il avait beaucoup de laïcs
c'était pas forcément convertir en vote
nicole nous dit il s'est ridiculisé mais
pire il a ridiculisé la fonction
babineau qui nous dit macro est en
précampagne même chez une partie de la
jeunesse les moins de 25 ans les moins
de 25 ans sa cote de popularité
progresse et loïs estime que la jeunesse
s'intéresse à la france à la politique
même et c'est qu'elle s'engage
différemment sur l'augmentation de la
popularité de
enfin la cote de popularité des manuels
macron il ya un effet qui est lié à ces
genres de prestations pour passer encore
trop tôt pour le dire faudra voir ce qui
est vrai c'est que là on sent qu'un
regain de popularité qui semble bien
liée à la sortie du comité s'est fait
que donc sur dans tous les strates de la
de l'opinion et dans tous les partis
on sent qu'ils remontent parce que gens
sont contents c'est fini et il a qu'ils
encouragent cette eau de pluie ça c'est
très bien je ne sais pas du tout la
question est et qu'il essaie d'en
profiter
après tout ils auraient tort de leurs
torts ne pas le faire le le sujet pas là
mais qu on est quand même que pour
quelqu'un qui prétendait restaurer la
dignité de la politique la verticalité
qui a commencé au louvre devant la
pyramide du louvre qui sur son command
car nous avions joué le yen
le monarque marmoréen et hiératique
mcphail carlito pas tout à fait ça on va
passer à l'autre trop de l'autre l'autre
buzz du week end c'est l'autre polémique
samedi audrey pulvar tête de liste ps en
ile-de-france trouver la présence de
gérald darmanin dans une manifestation
de policiers je cite soutenu par
l'extrême droite assez glaçante dimanche
tweet de gérald darmanin il attaque en
diffamation en estimant qu'on ne peut
pas diffamer la police de la république
et ce matin le ministre renonce
implicitement à la plainte et propose
une rencontre à audrey pulvar après
l'avoir entendu dire ceci sur lci
xo 10
je crois ce n'est pas mentir que de le
dire non la police française nie pas
raciste de façon systématique de façon
systémique
la plupart des policiers à des policiers
de notre pays remplissent leur mission
avec avec d'éducation et parfois paient
de leur vie
cet engagement il arrive que certaines
et certains se comporte mal et dans ces
cas là il faut les sanctionner
je crois enfoncer des portes ouvertes à
grands coups d'épaulé en disant ça
dominique est ce que de votre point de
vue gérald darmanin a eu raison pour
l'instant de renoncer à la plainte est
de proposer cette rencontre alors
renoncer à la plate ça me paraît une
bonne idée ce n'était pas une bonne idée
de d'imaginer déposé plainte pour de
tels propos n'ont pas voilà c'est passé
pas c'est pas sur ce terrain là que doit
se gagner cette bataille
et puis en général si je peux me
permettre cette remarque l'absence de
réaction aux propos
incriminés auraient été plus défavorable
à la candidate en ile de france que
depuis qu'il ya cette controverse parce
qu'évidemment ça ça lui donne de la
visibilité ça valorise pour une partie
de l'opinion ces propos même si elle les
a atténué comme on l'a vu ici sur une
série ne serait pas très habile en plus
j'ai trouvé cette idée d'attaquer en
diffamation
votre point de vue à tous est une ratage
total
déjà évidemment il fallait pas attaquer
pudeur en diffamation moi je suis en
désaccord 100 % à ce que tu aurais pu
voir en général et sur cette affaire de
la police en particulier je considère
comme la montre aigles large majorité
des français que accusés comme elle
l'avait fait quand malgré tout par le
passé dans un passé plus anciens la
police de racisme systémique mettrait en
cause systématiquement les violences
policières
c'est que c'est ce mal se comporter se
passe est conforme à la vérité et à
l'intérêt du pays
donc je suis en total désaccord mais a
le droit de dire on est quand même en
démocratie
je suis absolument pas d'accord il faut
se battre mais on peut pas le miz
l'intérieur peut pas interdire aux gens
de s'exprimer
enfin sur le plan des principes c'est
absurde et le résultat de tout ça c'est
bon un qu'il a été obligé de faire
marche arrière puis le choix parce que
de toute façon son truc tenait pas la
route
il n'y avait rien de juridiquement
reprochable dans ce qu'elle avait dit
mais non mais non seulement il fait
marcher à mais surtout il ay là il a
relancé la campagne depuis var qui avait
totalement disparu qui était dans les
choux dont plus personne ne parle et la
gauche était divisée mais mme hidalgo
étaient en train de lâcher
aujourd'hui elle se elle redevient
l'héroïne tout le monde est derrière
elle tout le monde est d'accord pour
dire que matt d'arman a eu tort de
l'attaqué toute la gauche y compris une
partie de la droite y compris une partie
des marcheurs qui disent c'est vraiment
très bête de l'avoir attaqué tout
qu'elle se retrouve sur un pavois par la
grâce de cette manoeuvre sublime c'est
quand même extraordinaire sur sur le
plan oui c'est ce que j'ai en fait on
comprend pas pourquoi qu'elle était là
le ressort de gérald darmanin est-ce que
c'est aussi le fait comme le disent
certains confrères que il a peu de marge
de manoeuvre pour donner satisfaction
aux syndicats de police et donc été
obligé de faire ça il est semble c'est
encore c'est une réaction qui est sans
doute significative de
l'hypersensibilité
de la police qui est le résultat aussi
d'une forme d'accablement de
l'hypersensibilité de la police à une
accusation récurrente ridicule les
récurrentes est extrêmement pénible à
entendre celle de racisme systémique par
exemple c'est accablant pour les
policiers c'est profondément injuste
c'est reconnu par tout le monde bien sûr
et je pense à lui salué tellement dit
dans les rencontres nombreuses que fait
le ministre l'intérieur avec la police
avait tellement dit que il a voulu
réagir rapidement j'imagine pour être en
empathie au fond avec le corps des
policiers qu'elle quelles conséquences
ça peut ça peut avoir ça peut avoir une
conséquence sur la campagne en
ile-de-france pour un terme pur aurait
pu le voir notamment et pour la config
schiesser nas qui passe ses journées
sont assez bons pour elle donc enfin
simon ammann avait voulu alors après on
peut prêter des scénario machiavélique
ce que je ne crois pas je pense qu'en
général en politique les choses
s'expliquent par la maladresse et
l'improvisation mais on pourrait dire
qu'il fait ça exprès pour pousser pulvar
pour affaiblir
pécresse je ne crois pas que ce soit ça
je pense simplement que il accuse oui il
est sur la défensive parce qu'ils
arrêtent pas d'essayer de prouver ces
policiers qui va les défendre mais qui
va obtenir des choses pour eux et que
d'ailleurs va manifester avec eux comme
des trucs bizarres dans celui de mise
intérieure va manifester non pas contre
lui-même quand on y met contre sa
majorité puisqu'il manifeste devant
l'assemblée avec les policiers qui
exigent et bonne loi mais si le premier
ennemi de l'intérieur veut des beaunois
il un truc à faire c'est déposer des
projets de loi c'est son maître c'est
son métier
donc il va le plus d'ailleurs veut
manifester pour exiger des lois ensuite
il va interdire à des opposants de
parler on a perdu quand même on en a
perdu la tête et ils essayent donc
d'obtenir sa de ce point de vue la
raison il c'est d'obtenir un ensemble
d'éléments factuels pour la police force
est de constater que c'est très
difficile
d'abord c'est difficile techniquement
ensuite didier derrière le conseil
national qui passe son temps au fur et à
mesure que qu'on bâtit des fragiles
souvent dans l'improvisation faut le
dire digg judiciaire et juridique pour
les pôles et policiers le poussaient
conçu à 2 les balaie les unes après les
autres et l'a récemment et comme un
salon de décision très mauvaise que les
flics les positions très mal ressenti et
notamment celle du fameux article 24
d'entre eux battu les oreilles et
finalement qu'ils retiraient pas ce que
ça marche pas juridiquement ça tient pas
la route sur les drones se tient pas la
route
il ya une disposition qui va qui va
faire beaucoup de bruit beaucoup de mal
ces dispositions déposée par un
parlementaire la reine mais soutenu par
dupont moretti qui est la présence des
avocats en perquisition on n'imagine pas
l'effet que ça va faire chez les
politiques que ça demandera de faire
chez les policiers
le fait d'avant de paris sur des chaises
un truand d'appeler l'avocate maître
nous allons pétitionner sur votre i en
voulez-vous venir avec nous c'est
évident que quand ils arrivent là plus
rien c'est obligatoire donc les
policiers sont vent debout contre cette
histoire-là d'armani n'y peut pas
grand-chose et invente de la surenchère
politico médiatique et se prend les
pieds dans le tapis parce que quand on
va trop vite qu'on veut en faire trop on
se plante
dominique c'est un interdit là en ce
moment il joue sa place c'est votre
point de vue aussi compte tenu de
l'importance du sujet
la sécurité intérieure la lutte contre
la criminalité la délinquance dans ton
public
on peut pas imaginer remplacer le
ministre de l'intérieur sauf à avoir une
très très bonne idée
d'ici la présidentielle parce que
pendant l'année ça va compter c'est dans
l'année qui vient et c'est très facile
de se débarrasser de quelqu'un c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de le remplacer
avantageusement quand on fait comme ça
voilà un tour d'horizon rapide en tout
cas on ne trouve pas aisément et gérald
darmanin est vraiment allé partout il va
partout tout le temps il épuise ses
équipes d'ailleurs je crois est donc
enfin il faut avoir au moins quelqu'un
qui fasse ça c'est déjà pas facile je
vois qu'il ya pas vraiment de coûter la
reine ou même à droite qui pourrait
prétendre avec toutes les réserves que j
y mets quand même prétendre incarner
cette politique la vision même vis-à-vis
des policiers il aurait cependant quand
il va la manifestation j'ai dit ce que
j'en pensais sur le plan des principes
les policiers reçoivent plutôt pas mal
du tout
le ministre est venu à leurs côtés donc
il le revoilà donc ils continuent
d'avoir une une certaine popularité
auprès des policiers dans l'opinion
dans mon souvenir les dames des
dernières études puis un débat mauvaise
pour lui il n'y a pas grand monde qui
aujourd'hui peut incarner une politique
de fermeté et ça paye qui fait redouter
jamais été autant de demandes est
réclamée à cor et à cri par l'opinion
oui mais si je vous suis finalement et
quand on voit justement ce qui est en
train de se faire au plan législatif
dans le fond dans le match entre dupond
moretti et
et
darmanin dans le match entre justice et
police l'avantagé putois dupond moretti
et va donc dans le sens attendu pour
mort et il faut mettre conseil constitue
en fait celui qui est des faits parce
que normalement il avait obtenu le vote
d'un certain nombre de dispositions
notamment sur les polices municipales
sur les questions des drones sur la
vidéosurveillance sur et tous et toutes
ces éléments là ont été ont été mis en
l'air par le consul par le conseil
constitutionnel
par ailleurs d'armes annales les
éléments que d'hermann à lui que dupont
moretti lui obtenu notamment le fait
qu'il faille tenir les enquêtes
préliminaires dans un délai serré chose
qui me paraît assez positive est
nécessaire mais évidemment ça fait pas
plaisir aux policiers qu'ils lisent va
alors on pourra plus faire dans un cadre
préliminaire comme on le faisait avant
mais ça ça reste ça reste dedans et si
cette affaire d'avocats reste dedans
les policiers à la fin nous n'aurons pas
gagné je vous donne je rappelle la
question qu'on vous pose sur twitter
gérald darmanin at il raison de tendre
la main à audrey pulvar alors poussez
pas votre point de vue pour des noms à
67%
mais effectivement dans votre
commentaire vous avez plutôt tendance à
dire que on pouvait pas trop porté porté
place crise sur le kriss kross qui nous
dit cela reste son opinion il n'y a pas
d'appel à la haine contre les policiers
oui la plainte de dharma n'a aucun
fondement juridique et contribue à la
judiciarisation du débat public
et christophe est un peu est un peu plus
ironique en lui disant d'armes annales
va passer chez mc fly et carlito pour
aussi pour montrer aux 15-25 ans qu'il
est cool mais à vous entendre il n'a pas
forcément besoin parce que le plus tôt
il est plutôt il est plutôt bien vue est
plutôt bien vue dans sa dans son action
will est plutôt bien perçue action je
n'ai pas regardé d'études précise
récemment mais de toute façon c'est sur
un sujet clé sur lequel l'opinion n'est
pas un sociable mais est en attente de
beaucoup de beaucoup de résultats il ya
des éléments quand même qu'il faut
souligner il faudrait être juste on n'a
pas le temps d'être justes ni d'être
avoir expertise suffisamment pour être
juste 5 est malheureux mais une des
raisons pour lesquelles il y à beaucoup
plus de scènes de violence dans les
quartiers de tirs au mortier et cetera
c'est que précisément la police avec
darmana y est envoyé
de plus en plus va bousculer des points
de deal des marchés de démarches et de
dealers perturbe donc une économie et
j'ai lu dans les pages du figaro ya un
vampire je ne sais plus que à marseille
dans certains quartiers on peut faire
cent cinquante mille euros en une
journée
donc ces deux grosses affaires d énorme
affaire donc du grand banditisme est
évidemment d'aller dans l'étape et là
dedans pour essayer de remettre un peu
d'ordre c'est ça provoque des réactions
et les dealers peut-être pas les petits
mais ceux qui sont au dessus savent très
bien que si on commence à mettre les
quartiers sans dessus dessous
le politique va s'inquiéter parce que
les élections approchent et peut-être va
céder devant la pression de l'opinion et
la proximité de l'élection il ya un jeu
politique aussi qui est menée par les
dealers
quand on lui dit lors on peut penser à
des petits revendeurs mais il ya aussi
au dessus
tous ceux qui organisent le trafic et
qui sont beaucoup plus politique oui je
pense qu'une grosse difficulté qui c'est
à dire qu'on a le sens du désir des
mesures et politiques quelle surenchère
verbale incessantes
c'est que l'opinion ne sont très
demandeuses très exigeante et se
satisfait plus de mots lorsque les gens
veulent c'est des résultats et obtenir
des résultats sur ce terrain là c'est
très très long et très difficile il
faudrait faire preuve d'une très grande
constance d'une très grande fermeté dans
le temps en mettant des moyens en
mettant des moyens
humains des moyens financiers des
ménages juridique ou toute chose que
cette majorité pas plus qu'une autre
peut faire dans l'année qui vient donc
le risque de toute façon de la déception
au bout du compte il est patent merci
beaucoup pour vos commentaires et vos
explications vos points de vue on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
et même peut-être tout à l'heure sur
europe 1 pour entendre justement
dominique reynié parler d'autre chose
c'est de son nouveau livre le 21e siècle
le siècle du christianisme et la une du
figaro demain d'un sujet qui peut
sembler inattendue mais qui va revenir
et forte dans les dents les radars c'est
la question de la nouvelle calédonie et
d'une un futur référendum sur
l'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
qui se profile et vous pouvez réécouter
d'ailleurs l'une des représentantes de
lille qui était l'invité du toc
distraire ce matin et qui était très
clair sur les différents enjeux merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis trt demain
donc rendez vous 17 heures avec
guillaume roquette et mathieu soupière
et jérôme sainte-marie à très vite sur
figurent die